parfois en plein pendant une phase de
sommeil paradoxal il y a un bug au
niveau de notre cerveau normalement à ce
moment là la zone de notre cerveau qui
gère l'état de conscience donc l'éveil
et la zone qui gère les mouvements donc
les muscles elles fonctionnent en même
temps et bah ce qui crée ces situations
de paralysie du sommeil c'est une
dissociation entre ces deux zones donc
notre esprit est réveillé mais pas notre
corps tous nos muscles sont complètement
paralysés le cœur ou les muscles
respiratoires par exemple eux ils
continuent à fonctionner de manière
autonome évidemment tout s'accélère et
notamment la respiration c'est ce qui
donne cette impression des soufflements
voire de d'oppression ou d'étouffement
qui nous fait penser qu'on va pas tarder
à décéder Dieu il fonctionne donc on
peut les ouvrir regarder partout autour
de nous et voir tout ce qui se passe
quand on rêve notre cerveau il s'invente
tout un tas de scénarios plus ou moins
what the fuck autour de ce qui nous Titi
psychologiquement pendant la journée et
ben là c'est pareil ça part en délire
mystique à base de bestioles assises sur
notre thorax ou de monstre qui nous
guette mal dans un camp de notre chambre